Rigo rapid recovery plus was developed  in close collaboration with team sky and  it was to meet their demands for  recovery after particular springless  events but the Tour de France where  there is a need to recover from one day  to the next day and continue to perform  at a high level even though it was  developed with Team Sky it has a lot of  relevance to ride us on the track  because they're also pushing their  muscles to the limit  causing some muscle damage using fuel ie  carbohydrates at a very high rate so the  need to restore the carbohydrate in the  muscle to repair the muscle and to  replace the electrolytes lost in space  as identical